thank you all for coming i don't
recognize any of you nor can i recall
why i'm here now without further ado
my name is aaron powell and this is
docker from scratch uh there's some
contact details and stuff if you want to
find me afterwards or follow me on
twitter or anything like that i'll also
be around the retify booth just around
the corner for most of the day if you
want to come and have a chat
after this talk
so obviously this is a talk about docker
when we talk about docker we talk about
a whole bunch of different things we
talk about things like immutable
infrastructure or
doing containerized architectures using
micro services and deploying them into
cloud infrastructure using kubernetes or
dcos or swarm
we talk about how we can use docker to
make our development environment almost
identical to our product and production
environment how we you know we build
this stuff and we ship it and nothing
changes as we roll across all the
different environments that we're using
within our application we have no
rollback we always roll forward and all
that kind of stuff
this is not a talk about that part of
docker
we are not going to be covering off
things like kubernetes or anything like
that
this is a talk about the basics
this is a talk targeted to people that
maybe doc has been something that
they've wanted to learn but have just
never found the time or it's something
that you've heard about but you don't
even know what it's what its concepts
are how to use it or like what value it
could bring into what you're building as
applications or anything like
that this is a talk where we're going to
start from scratch and throughout the
course of the talk we'll understand what
i mean why and why i'm putting the
emphasis emphasis on from scratch
so
there's a bunch of other docker content
that will cover off all the stuff that i
showed in the previous slides you know
things about
you know doing clustered architecture in
production and all that kind of stuff so
kind of this could be a entry point to
you know maybe i want to go and learn
some more about that afterwards
hopefully that's what you take away from
this talk but i said this is this is
intended to help you get started with
docker and kind of talk about my
experience when i first was getting into
docker and uh working out where to go
from there
so i want to just start with some useful
terminology so that we understand a bit
about what docker is and some of the
concepts that i'm going to introduce
over the course of this talk so that we
can understand them in the context of
what we're going to be doing
so first off i just want to clarify
docker is not a virtual machine
docker is about
isolation it's uh it's come from like
linux and the unix world
a concept called ch root
which is basically creating user space
isolation with inside of the kernel
so you are
almost running something that is a
full-blown uh
linux kernel uh with inside of it but
it's still separate from uh the other
processes are running here it's often
thought about almost like process
isolation as well
the terminology that i'm going to use a
lot is the idea of an image an image is
your starting point when
building something from docker
an image is used
to baseline a bunch of reproducible
output
uh
thinking about it from i'm i'm a
developer from or that's my background
i'm not an ops person so i think of
things in developer context and when i
think about an image
from an oo programming perspective an
image is a class definition
from that we then have containers a
container is a running image
it's made from some kind of image that
we started with so it's the
implementation of a class it's an object
created from a class again using an oo
programming analogy there
um
often times when uh when i was first
getting started with docker or when i'm
talking to people about docker they'll
often confuse the the idea of an image
and a container and they think that the
words are usually used interchangeably
but they're not they're very different
concepts and we'll see how that happens
and and what the differences are as we
start doing some of the demos uh shortly
and the final bit of technology i want
to talk about is the host the host is
the machine that is running docker i'm
running a windows laptop i'm going to be
using linux docker containers
so that kind of works a little bit
differently than if i was running a
native linux laptop um i'm not going to
be talking about windows containers i
think there's some other content
throughout the week if you're interested
in windows containers because there's
some fundamental differences between
linux and windows containers but
basically
the crux of it is
the host is the machine that docker is
installed on for all intent and purpose
docker is installed on my windows
machine and i'm going to be working with
linux how that works um
i can chat to you afterwards if you want
to understand some of the nitty gritty
internals but i won't dive too much into
that
so
we tend to interact with docker from a
command line uh this is a standard
command that you might be running with
docker uh so it's made up of the docker
cli tool that we work with um
we then provide that with a command that
we're gonna execute against docker in
this case it's a run command
we have some options that we passed to
run a it flag and a dash dash rm and
i'll talk about what those do
throughout the demos that we do in a
moment
we then have some arguments we pass to
the command
this is actually those two arguments
here the first is the image that we're
going to be using so that's ubuntu
and then
some kind of an execution executable to
run with inside of the ubuntu container
and this case it's going to be slash bin
bash
okay so that's enough time spent in
powerpoint we're going to spend pretty
much the rest of the talk at a command
line as i go through live demos and
we're going to cross our fingers and
hope that none of my live demos fail um
i gave this talk a couple of days ago
and i got through most of them without
any failures but you know today is a new
day so let's see how how kind the
demogods are going to be to meet today
i'm going to start with the canonical
hello world example of docker
so i've got that command uh whoops i
probably should close my slide so that
everyone actually can see my command
line
okay
okay so i've got a command here
that i'm going to execute pretty much
similar to the one that we had with
inside of the powerpoint slides just a
moment ago using docker run i'm passing
in a flag dash i t
this flag or this argument i'm passing
to run is to say that i want an
interactive docker container started so
this allows me to then
connect to std in essentially and i can
type and interact with that container as
it's been run
then we're starting with the ubuntu
image and executing the command bin bash
so let's run that
so here we go i've been dropped into
what looks like a unix prompt
i can run unix commands such as ls ac
here i've got
a file system very unix looking file
system
and now i'm because now i am running
inside of an ubuntu image i can
make directory uh call it foo so i can
then
create something that
sits at the root of this file system a
folder called foo so on and so forth
so my container is up and running i can
you know do a whole bunch of stuff with
that and i can
see what it uh
play around with a linux machine running
on my windows box
i can also run a command and i'll just
edit it from another another shell
called ps which
this lists the containers that are
running on my machine so you can see
i've got a container here it's got a
container id of four nine fe zero zero a
and so on and so forth uh it started
from an ubuntu image it had a command it
was created 47 seconds ago it was still
up 45 seconds ago
it's got a name of loving men's
obviously i've got this zoomed a little
bit so it wouldn't normally wrap but for
the sake of readability particularly
people are back i've
increased the font size of touch but it
would normally format it a little bit
better so
there's my running container i can see
it and find some basic information about
it
i can exit that container drop back to
my command line if i come over here and
docker ps again
that container's been stopped it's not
running anymore because i sent i i
exited the application that the
container was running so it's shut down
because it's running just a single
process until it's until that process is
told to not run any longer
i can still see that container by
running docker ps dash a
or expand that to double dash all so
this lists all containers uh regardless
of their status on the machine ps just
lists the the current uh running images
running containers whereas this is
listing all containers started and
stopped so you can see here i have one
it was exited 19 seconds ago
now i could say docker and if i wanted
to do something with that container
let's say i want to restart it
i can do docker start
and then
i need to provide it some kind of unique
identifier for that container that i
want to start in this case i want to
start container id 4 9 f etc etc but
because i only have to provide enough
uniqueness that docker can work out the
rest for me i can give it just four i
can give it four nine i tend to just use
two characters because that tends to be
as much uniqueness as you necessarily
need i could also use the name loving
benz if i wanted to as well so i can
start that docker ps and we can see that
was up one second ago i can then attach
to it
and i'm back on there
ls and we see that file system that we
saw before you can see that the food
folder is still there and all that kind
of stuff
uh if i was to do docker stop
49
i can then send a stop command to that
running container
which can be coming back over to this
terminal so that's containers exited i'm
back at my powershell prompt instead of
being my my bash prompt that i was
before so uh
what that essentially has done is it
sends um it sent a an exit signal across
to the running container which is then
told the process that's running in that
container to exit and it will gracefully
shut down
uh the final thing i'm just going to
remove that container so docker rm
let's do some cleanup remove 49. now if
i do docker ps
i have nothing left in my container list
either running or stopped
okay
so that's like i said a kinetic
canonical hello world example
let's go to something else
all right so
this is where we start seeing the
difference between an image and a
container and because an image is our
starting point i can make multiple
containers based off of the same image
and that's what i'm doing here i'm
creating three different
ubuntu containers but they're all based
off of the same ubuntu image
i've added a couple additional flags
dash d which starts this container in a
detached mode so while it is still
a dash i t so it's still interactive
it's detached which means that my
terminal is not immediately connected to
it i have to use docker attached to then
attach that
that container later on
passing dash dash rm flag which
basically means that when this container
stops
remove yourself
this is really useful when you're doing
prototyping or demos like this and stuff
like that i i want to start off a bunch
of containers but i don't want them
sitting around like
that space on disk that i don't need
particularly if i'm just testing
something out or prototyping typing
something i just want it to to go away
when i'm done i'm also doing dash name
which is giving this a i'm specifying
the name so instead of getting a
uniquely generated name like loving
underscore benz i'm saying that these
are named ubuntu one through three
so let's run that
so starting up the multiple containers
and you'll see that it's output the
ids of each of those containers that
have been run
and now i can go over and attach them
so i'm just going to open up a couple
more powershell terminals
just resize them with touch okay so if
we do docker attach ubuntu 1
docker attach one two
two and then
i bet you can guess what i'm attaching
to here
if i can type correctly okay whoops
it entered properly on all of them okay
cool now i'm inside of all three of
these
uh let's take number one and just make
directory of through at the root be ls
on that one and then say go to number
two
well they
they started with the same looking file
system they because they're all isolated
they don't know about each other they
can't talk to each other um
they don't share a file system anything
i do on the file system of one container
is not available to the file system of
another container so
i've obviously added a folder to one but
it's not available anywhere else so i i
have that isolation of process so this
batch process is isolated per container
if i was to say docker stop ubuntu
two we'll stop that one uh my middle
powershell terminal has dropped back to
just the powershell prompt and if we do
uh process list all
uh you'll see that i only have ubuntu
one and three running because the uh
because it had the rm flag it cleaned
itself up when it stopped
cool and let's just exit the others i
don't need them open for
um
any longer we've killed everything that
we needed all right so let's just clean
everything up
a little bit
until focus comes in and let's go to our
next demo
all right
so i said that the file systems are
isolated so i can't i don't know what
happens in ubuntu one in ubuntu i don't
have any way to interact between them
but what if i did want to have something
that's shared between them
these are transients so far that if i
kill them i remove them i don't have any
of the files that was created within
them i've got no way to get those files
back out
and this is where i want to introduce
the concept of docker volumes you see a
new argument that i've included here
dash v
dash v is short for volume and what that
does is it creates a mount point between
the host that the container has been run
from
and the container itself so it takes an
argument that's um got two parts to it
one which is the directory of the local
container the directory on the host that
you want to mount
and then what is the folder on the
container that you want to mount that to
so because i'm running this in a
batch file
i'm mounting the current working
directory percent cd percent and i'm
going to mount that to a directory
called slash files
now this one
it also introduces something that i tend
to use docker for and that is like
executing a single process that i
maybe don't want to have on my actual
machine
i treat my laptop as a very transient
device if it dies i'll take it to the
microsoft store and go it's dead
and hopefully they'll give me a new one
it doesn't necessarily work that way but
that's at least the hope
so i don't tend to install a whole lot
of software on my machine
i'll have some you know core tools that
i use day-to-day but you know
i had a scenario the other month where
uh i was doing a technical interview at
retify and someone had sent me a raf
file of
a coding exercise that we get candidates
to do
it's a a raw file
i was like i checked my watch
it was still 2017
i hadn't gone back to 2005 and had not
paid for a winrar license still
uh i was like as an archiving format i
don't remember the last time i like used
rar in the wild i had a similar instance
with 7-zip so like that one was even
more obscure
so i don't have anything on my machine
that can un-rather
well okay so what's what would someone
normally do they'd go and download 7-zip
but not me
i i'm going to use this once
so i'm going to find a docker image that
does it i don't actually like i don't
need 7-zip long-term i just i want to be
able to run a process terminate and it's
gone away and i don't need it anymore
so i found a docker image out there
max c
and something something slash
unra so this usually uses the the unix
unrar command
and
amount of volume of my machine
and then i tell it to unrar that
particular file
so let's just run that uh so this is not
the code that the candidate send me i
was not going to show that uh from a
privacy standpoint i did not want to
share that uh
ndc this is something i found in my
inbox
from there's a raw file or something
from codeplex from 2010 i think
so
it's some really old code um
okay cool uh
oh hang on
i need to
need to delete it from when i ran the
demo earlier today and just made sure
everything still worked
okay so let's just try again
so here we go it's unraring a whole
bunch of
net code
dropping that to disk and then
i have
here
a trunk folder which is then the
contents of that raw file and you'll
have to obviously trust me that that's
the contents of that raw file but you
can see the output window um did
that there we go that's how you can use
docker for just like a single run
process you know something you just want
to prototype with or something you want
to play around with you don't want to
have to go through the whole effort of
installing three versions of java
because you want to test across three
different java runtimes you can just
pull down a docking container of each of
the different versions and test an
application against those
so speaking of java
let's go on to our next demo
so this is not java this is node
um
there's that many versions of node and
every other week there's either a
preview build or there's a new long-term
service build that's out or something
like that so if you're building
something on node and
maybe you're building like a
redistributable package and something
you're publishing in open source how do
you effectively make sure that that
works across quite a large variety of
node versions
well the easiest way is pull down a
docker image that has of all the
different versions that you want to test
with
make a container from that
run your test inside of it see if it
passes there we go
rather than
you know having to install something
like nvm and manage multiple local
installs of node and stuff like that you
quite easily use the docker image for
that
so
we run this starts up and we have
console.log
hello in dc
so i'm inside of the node.js rebel
because that's where i've been dropped
by running this um this command you'll
notice uh that i didn't have a argument
past
the node colon
version number because i just want to
execute whatever the default command
that that image would run when a
container is created from that in this
case it's just going to execute no dot
exe well sorry it's not going to execute
node. it actually is going to just
execute node it's no exits unix
so i end up inside of the node repl so i
can do like const fs
and then pull in like node modules
uh if i
hey there's another demo value excellent
um and then do like fs read directory
of slash
and then errors paths
paths so if we just log all of that out
we realize that i've fat fingered
something else and
yeah it's
paths i call the variable path and then
i'd call paths when i try and output it
so but there we go so that's like inside
of then a document container so i can
use node to inspect that and you see
that it's still a unix file system at
the at the end of the day i can see all
the same stuff there so i can traverse
it um that's good for
interacting with a particular single
process and this is obviously a single
process that's running with inside of
my container i don't have kind of the
ability to do anything else with it cool
so let's jump out of that
clear it off and we'll go on to
number five
okay so
this time i want to do something i i
want to actually run an application with
inside of node with inside of a
container so i've got a application here
um i'm not going to go into the details
about how this node app works i don't
want this to become a node talk i i
appreciate that this is probably a
fairly complex node application so i
don't want to i don't want to dwell on
how node works or anything like that but
the crux of it is it's going to be a web
server
so just just trust me that that's a web
server in node
[Laughter]
so i'm going to start up a server i'm
going to bind that to port 3000 uh and
then i want to be able to obviously get
a response from that okay so
we'll run
oh
sorry i'll just go back uh so we're
using volume mounting again you'll see
we're mounting the source into a src
directory i'm also then running another
command another argument dash w which
sets the working directory
for the process that's being executed to
slash src so the where i've mounted to
uh they've got the image then and then
i'm saying you're going to execute
instead of just dropping you at the node
repl i want to execute a particular
node a particular file using the node.js
application so i'm going to execute node
and app.js now if i didn't so it knows
where that file is because of the slash
w flag if i didn't do that i could do
like slash src
app.js and it would
do exactly the same thing
okay cool so we'll start that up run
that into touch mode so the
server is up and running um
and i can
docker ps
see that yeah cool there we go it's up
and running all right so let's go curl
localhost
localhost
3000.
we've got an error it hasn't been able
to resolve or it couldn't connect to the
server well but hang on a sec i said
like
i didn't fat finger that right i said it
was port 3000 if we go back to app.js
yep supposed to be listed on port 3000
okay
um maybe there's something in the logs
so docker logs node
server's up and running if i
tell it to follow the logs
well it's like the process is definitely
running because they're still trying to
write logs out
okay well
uh let's just go curl again
local host 3000
well it didn't crash the process like
there's nothing in my logs that says
it's crashed
well what's gone wrong
i know what's gone wrong because i wrote
these demos right
so what's happened is
the process is running it's listening on
that port but i haven't told it
to actually map inbound connections to
that port so let's have a look at the
information about this container
so i can use node inspect and then
provide it with an id3 container so i've
inspected the node container that we've
got running and there is a
network section here
and here
in lies
the problem
the container itself has not got any
ports mapped to it
the container itself is running the
container the application inside of the
container is listening on that port but
the container doesn't have any ports
bound to its host
okay cool so we'll just uh stop
the node container we'll come back over
here
that'll exit in a moment
so this so this is where um stop is
useful because it's sending a because
it's sending the shutdown command to
that process
um
it's not doing like a hard stop it's not
just you know uh doing like a a kill
dash uh dash f or anything on that it's
sending the proper sig term processes uh
commands across to the process so it
will shut down gracefully so if you do
have an application running it will then
do all the proper cleanup you know if
it's got to
release database connections and stuff
like that it can do all that clean up
nicely before it shuts down it's not
just you've pulled the power from me
okay so let's go to step
six
okay
and we'll come back to our run
and now
we have a dash p flag
so the dash p is that we're going to do
port binding so dash p is port uh you
can have as many dash p's as you want
with inside of it and you can so you can
bind multiple ports to a container so
the process can list on listen on
multiple ports this could be useful if
you're running something like uh
rabbitmq is a good example of this it
has the management port and it has the
the cue listening port so you you could
bind two ports on that
and the the port bindings kind of
similar to the way that we do volume
mounting is
something on the host column
something on the container so in this
case i can map whatever port i want on
my host to port 3000 on the container
and to illustrate this on map port 8080
on my host through to port 3000 on the
container
so we'll run that again
and we can
pop that up
it's clear and if we curl
local localhost
hey you think i'd be better at writing
localhost by now like how many years
i've been writing that out
so if i now call on 8080 excellent there
we go
we've got our hello world back as we
expected uh 3000 will still send back
that error that we
again that we would expect because we're
not binding anything to port 3000 on my
host it's not being able to do any any
redirections across to a container so if
we go back and say docker inspect node
so just go back and have a look at what
our network settings now look like
you see that ports
the array of ports has been fleshed out
a bit we have port 3000 on tcp so you
can map both udp and tcp ports into a
docker container obviously i'm only
doing tcp in this case
uh what i p on the host so if you've got
like multiple um nics within side of the
host that you're running docker on you
could map incoming requests on one
particular nick across to a particular
container um if so desired uh so that's
what the host ip is all about and then
the host port is what port on my machine
so yeah like i said you can map whatever
port you want locally across to whatever
port you want on your server so you can
have everything listening on port 80
with inside of docker containers
but on
local dev or in
inside of your production system before
your reverse proxy they're all running
on like random ports and stuff like that
now when you do port binding you don't
have to do the uh the host port colon
syntax you can just do i want to bind
like port 3000. what i'll do is it'll
randomly choose a port
on your machine and then you're gonna
have to go into docker inspect and find
out what that port is and stuff like
that just a bit annoying
also we can do docker ps
and we'll see the port information uh
across on the far right hand side of
that left hand side of that
right
wait it's backwards to me anyway you get
my point
and we can also see there all the
different ports that we've got bound
okay so let's just stop
node again and we're going to jump over
to our next demo
all right so
our command that we're getting was like
it was starting to get a little bit big
to run our node application
we had to volume out we had to specify
ports we set working directories um
like a whole bunch of stuff like we're
having to set and if i want to get a
colleague on my team to just hey check
out this like little note app that i've
written uh it's just it's really useful
just parsing out you're
downloading all your payslips from your
um
when you're transitioning between
payroll systems which is something we're
we're actually doing at ratify at the
moment uh
having to send round this like massive
command line argument set that you got
to do someone is going to fat finger
that at some point and it's like and
then i get the call and say hey uh your
command doesn't work it's like oh okay
so how do we make that a bit more
reproducible
well we can start building our own
images to do that
and this is where i want to introduce
another file
called dockerfile uh so a dockerfile is
an instruction set it's a dsl of how to
create an image
uh in docker
and
it's there we then use that to basically
execute a bunch of commands that we can
then create an image that we can then
run as a container later on
so we always start with a from command
inside of our docker file because our
docker image that we're creating has to
start from something else and think
about the title from scratch
that's what the
that was the joke
yeah
um so in this one this image i'm doing
uh from node 774
particular build of that i'm saying that
this image exposes port 3000 so that's
just telling people that are going to be
starting this as a container later on
that
they know that they're going to need to
do some port mapping
should they so desire they cannot do
port mapping it's just not going to be a
very useful application
i'm going to run a command on that image
which is going to make a directory
called src
and instead of doing volume mounting so
the person doesn't have to volume out
that on their machine and i don't have
to ship them the app.js file i'm
actually going to execute the copy
command which will then copy the file
from my machine into the image
it's copying it into the src folder and
set the working directory as src and
then cmd
excuse me is the command that the
container will execute when it starts up
so it's going to execute node app.js
now this time instead of just like i
can't just use docker run because i'm
trying to create an image here right and
docker runs all about running containers
from an image so to do that first i need
to build an image from my docker file so
this is where we use the docker build
command docker build dash t so i'm going
to tag that image with something that i
can understand rather than just like
dealing with the massive image id that i
would normally get that i would get
generated i'm going to tag this as my
node.js app i have to tell it where to
find the docker file so i'm just saying
dot current directory uh if i
so by convention it will look for a file
named docker file you can change that
file name to whatever you want but then
you have to specify another argument
that is the name of the docker file with
inside of a working with inside of a
particular directory by convention
docker file is just a is what people
would be using so on line five we build
an image and then on line seven we're
going to do docker run
immediately remove on shutdown we do our
port binding
detach and then the node.js application
so we're going to start that image
as a container i'm not going to send any
commands after that because i would just
want it to execute its default command
so we run that
so the first thing uh it's doing the
build and you'll see that it's going
through each step that i've got in that
docker file
from a particular
base container it'll pull that down if i
don't already have it it will execute
expose so that that's put in there so on
and so forth and now i have a built
image at the end of the day which i can
then start as a container which i have
done and that's
h6e etc so i can go back and execute my
curl
on local host
eddy
there we go
now i can do docker images
and i can list out all the images that
i've got on my machine so you'll see
there on the top i've got a new one
called node.js app it was created 33
seconds ago it has a size of 59
megabytes
because that's basically the side of the
size of a node.js image
that i'm using here and i've added a
couple of k over the top of that or
maybe 1k over the top of that
and obviously i've got a whole bunch of
other images already on my machine
so now i can just do docker stop node
that will stop that container oh wait no
i didn't give it a name there was eight
uh we'll stop that one
shut it down and then i can remove that
image if i don't want it on my machine
anymore
a sec
terminate process
if we do docker
rmi so we used rm to remove a container
rmi to remove an image
and this will be node.js app
and we've deleted a whole bunch of um
stuff that was inside of uh on disk for
me so i've freed up a bit of uh disk
space
cool so that's how we can create
something that we can ship as a reusable
and that's where you can start seeing
how you would build applications and
then you start sharing an application
that's a containerized
architecture around and it starts from
this docker file is where we really
start with
all right so on to our next demo
all right we still had a couple of
command line arguments we had to execute
there though we still had to say that we
you know we wanted to do some port
bindings and so on and so forth
there's another way that we can start up
a
docker container and that is with docker
compose
docker compose is really useful about
how we can start describing an
environment that we want to run using
using docker
so this by convention uses a file called
docker dash
compose.yaml or dot yml uses the yaml
syntax to create that
so
i've got a very basic docker
compose file here it's got two
components to it it's got services and
it's got networks
services are the containers that you're
going to start with inside of your
dockerfile
and then networks are
how we can do some isolation i'm not
going to dive too much in networks right
now because we're going to see networks
a bit later on
so
here we can pre-define a bunch of stuff
though i can pre-define
my port binding so i can say that port
8080 is going to bind onto port 3000
i can specify the when it's built it's
going to build and a particular docker
file that's going to be built from and
this if i had multiple applications i
could start writing out multiple
services with inside of here
now this time we're going to use a
different command line tool docker dash
compose composes is essentially a
separate product with inside of the
docker family so we we have docker
compose instead of docker space compose
it's not a command on the docker cli
uh so on line five i'm using docking
pose uh specifying the file that i want
to use as my compose file current
working directory dot compose yaml
and i'm gonna say stand up that
environment
but in particular i want to stand up the
node service with inside of that compose
file so i've had multiple services i
could stand all of them up by just doing
docker compose up
if i wanted to stand up one i'd do
docker compose and then the specific
service name which is what i'm doing
here
uh line seven is uh once that process is
exited i just wanna do a docker compose
clean up so docking compose rm and i'm
just doing a force rm you know kill
everything with fire so that's how you
would stand up and then
clean up with using docker compose
oops
so if we run
now you'll see it's doing a few
different things it's creating
it creates a network it's creating that
image again because i
deleted that image in the last step um
of the last demo so it's got to create
that image from scratch
and then it's started that
container from that image you see right
at the bottom node underscore one which
is the name that's been assigned uh it's
up and running
and then uh we can do we do our curl but
i won't do that demo again um because
we've seen it all run before uh but you
can see yeah there we go uh you'll
notice that the the name of both the
image and the running container uh have
um a prefix on them and that's the
current working directory the so docker
from scratch is my
current folder so that's that's how it's
done that you can use in the compose
file you can control the name and we'll
see that shortly
so
just to exit
the node.js process it's going to shut
down
give it a second while that process is
exiting
stop there we go
oops
there we go and then that's done all of
it's clean up again
all right
on to
more demos
all right so
like i said i tend not to install
software on my machine
if i can help it
as a net developer so it does a lot of
asp.net
web dev
there's one thing that you kind of can't
get away with not installing and it's
sql server
until docker
so
i don't actually have sql server
installed on my machine instead i use
sql server inside of a docker container
and that's using the
linux implementation of microsoft sql
server from from microsoft
and i can quite easily start that up i'm
going to use a compose file again to do
this
just because it simplifies some stuff so
binding port so port 1433 which is the
standard sql server port
i'm creating a new network that i'm
going to shove all that stuff in there
the image is microsoft ms sql linux
server linux
and then i have to provide some other
stuff
this is a sql server you've got to
accept a license agreement i'm probably
going to want an sa password on that so
i can connect to it and you know be able
to interact with it
so we use environment variables here and
that's what that new section in the
compose file is for
we have an environment section and these
are environment variables that are going
to be inside of that container so inside
of that container if i was to echo m
i would say accept underscore euler
is y and we would see my super strong sa
password
so
if we were to
run that
so this time using docker compose i'm
actually not building a new image i'm
just running the
the baseline sql server image uh
there we go it's uh it's crashed for
some lovely reason that is deep within
side of sql server
uh
awesome um you can trust me that that
would normally work
uh so
um
what i'm not doing here is i'm not doing
any kind of volume mounting or anything
like that if you if you are running a
database be it a sql server or [ __ ] or
any kind of anything with persistent
stories you're probably going to want to
volume out so that
as the container is shut down you don't
lose all the data that's in your
database or your your redis case or
whatever it might be
cool i'm not going to try and debug why
that's failed i've got plenty of other
demos that we can get onto
anyway and hope that none of them also
suffer the same fate because most of
them require sql server
okay
uh wait where was i okay cool
so
i'm now uh i want to talk about how we
can use the compose to actually start
representing our environment that's what
i said that is is one of the useful
aspects of the compose file is that you
can represent how your whole application
architecture would look so to do this
i'm just going to send up i've got
an asp.net core application that runs
inside of a docking container and
i want to this asp.net application i
wanted to then talk to a sql server
but because i don't have sql server
installed i'm going to rely on
uh
on this and i just realized i forgot to
increase my font size in every increase
in everything but visual studio
uh so
visual studio actually has pretty decent
support for docker uh it does have some
rough edges that i've hit a couple of
times doing these demos and
fingers crossed that i don't get hit by
them right now if they do i'm gonna have
to quickly try and make them work and
we'll just do a little song and dance
and everyone you know don't watch as
things fail
but i've now got two services with
inside of this
compose file i have the demo app which
is my asp.net core application um it's
got a docker file that it starts uh
bases itself off uh which tells it to
use the asp.net call one one um docker
image stuff like that uh we're gonna
stand that up and it's to be up and
running and then sql server is also
going to be stood up
basically all the same information that
we had previously and
what i'm actually going to be doing is
i'm going to be putting them on i've got
multiple networks to find so that's the
other thing that i've got in here you
see at the bottom i've got two networks
um one with one called web and one
called db
because what i'm starting to do is i'm
defining my architecture that maybe my
sql server
that's not going to be publicly
accessible it's going to be on a network
that's firewall blocked you can't access
that from the public internet so i'm
putting this into a separate network
to the web server
but the web server still needs to be
able to talk to the sql server so
they're also going to share a network
and we'll see how we can do some fun
stuff with network isolation uh as we
sort of explore these demos but and i
start off by hitting f5 and
watching to see whether or not visual
studio is just going to do an operation
error
which is what it has been doing a couple
of times on me through these demos
okay so it's basically going through
this compose file it's executing a bunch
of stuff
creating a couple of images
it then has a compile error which i've
not hit before and this is where i start
crying a little to myself
um no it's actually got a bunch of stuff
hanging around from earlier on uh
just make sure i have so i have
something up and running i'm just gonna
kill
so if you don't care about sending a a
nice exit code you could kill dash f
uh sorry uh i can not kill uh docker rm
f it's like i just want this container
to go away
bam
that'll kill that that doesn't send a
nice shutdown to the process it's
running it's just like bam you're dead
um and that's then gonna hopefully and
then rm means it's gonna clean itself up
uh
i just need to clean up some networks i
think
yep work
prune uh yep let's get rid of all the
networks that i don't actually need and
now hopefully i'll be able to
check what i've got in my images i'm
just gonna remove the
demo
demo app
image as well so that ah
dash
i can forcibly remove an image so if i
try and remove an image that a container
is running on it'll stop me if i dash f
it's just kill i just
go like get rid of everything um so that
gets rid of that and
psa
so i now actually have to actually i
have to kill these images docker
uh rm-f of 31
55b and 16.
and that is how we kill with fire
anything that's running in docker
uh just ps make sure everything's gone
images
network
all right cool we are hopefully
back to
being in a position where i can hit f5
and not have visual studio complain at
me
one of the fun things about doing live
demos is that if you do actually want to
practice you've got to make sure that
you really clean up after yourself
excellent
operation failed in visual studio so
this is where we do the song and dance
as my demos just completely fall apart
um i just have to go back and re-execute
all those rms
again rm-f
e5 and 13.
images
um i of demo app
dev
and docker network
froon
oops prune yes
all righty we are going to relaunch
visual studio
um the visual studio docker tooling it
seems that
i i and this i'm just going to like
totally eat my words in about two
minutes time uh but it seems that if it
if you've got visual studio running
you've tried to execute a bunch of stuff
in docker they have failed it then sort
of hangs around inside of visual studio
and you can't re-kill it which is really
kind of frustrating so you have to kind
of close visual studio kill everything
open visual studio um cross your fingers
hit f5 again cry to yourself when it
doesn't work and go thank you for coming
um
see me outside and i might try and get
it working at another point um
yeah i actually i i hit that operation
exception um earlier today so i i'm
getting quite good at recovering from
that point uh as as you can see by the
fact that i've been able to just talk
through um a pretty spectacular demo
failure and visual studio error and a
bunch of stuff like that all right cool
so our web application is up and running
um
i can
i have a sql server that is also up and
running and i can prove it this time
because i have link pad here
and i'm connecting connecting to
uh localhost for
team 1433
there is currently no databases in there
other than the standard sql server
databases
and let's register with inside of our
application
uh
demo user
this is where i try and remember what
the password policy that i have on this
application is because i did like 10
attempts to register um the other day oh
sweet there we go uh okay cool so
this is talk to the sql server the sql
server has gone well
you don't actually have the database
ready
that's cool i mean your first migrations
just gonna run those
give it a couple of moments so this is
the the web server is talking to that
it's going to run the it's going to set
up the identity database with inside of
that because i'm just using local
identity i'm not using anything there i
can refresh the
page actually no we won't
log in
instead i'll come back here
that
we have created a database called doc
from scratch
inside of a sql server that's running on
docker using efs code migrations from a
web server that's running in docker as
well
so this is
this is now starting to look like what
we might want to use as a production
architecture and you're probably not
going to want to use the sql the
defaults
asp.net core application in production
but you get the idea
i could then go through the registration
process
create myself an account um
and
password
there we go
register there we go i'm now logged in
as a user um now if i was to stop
everything
and then start it all back up that
database would still have the data with
inside of it so i could then re-log in
because it's still that same container
it's just being shut down and restarted
if i was to remove that container
and then launch the application again i
wouldn't be able to log in because i
will have killed all that data and this
is where volume mounting is useful so
you'd mount all the um the directories
that sql server writes it's um it's
actual data based files too um you'd
mount that as a volume and then you
would basically persist that across you
know machines or
whatnot
cool um
the the other thing that if we just do
docker ps that will notice is that it's
been given this name the sql server in
particular has been given this name of
demo app underscore sequel um so like
that's given some conventions based off
of the um
the context where the con the compose
file was executed
uh that could be a little bit annoying
for how we want to connect to that
database like what's it actually named
if we want to connect to it
well this is where networks can become
really useful so you'll see here in the
network section of the sql database i've
said that the database that's here the
container name is going to be demo app
underscore sql because i've specified
that but the alias of that container
inside of that network is called sql
so that
when i look at my app settings
and i look at the database connection
string here i'm just saying sql 1433
so i don't really care what the name of
that container that's been started is
i don't even have to specify a name i
can just
call it lovely benz if you want to call
it lovely bends
docker when you first launch it but the
alias that's going to have on the
network is going to be sql so this is
kind of like if you're doing a hostname
hack inside of windows
cool okay so i'm just going to kill
everything docker
stop i don't know docker rm kill with
fire
6e
588
and then we're gonna
docker
rmi of demo app
dev and docker network prune clean up
all the networks that we've generated
and now i'm going to check out another
demo
so like i said
part of what we hopefully wanting to do
is we want to use networks to start
segregating things and maybe represent
something that's behind a firewall that
can't be externally accessed
well i mean i don't want my sql server
publicly accessible i might have a super
strong sa password like this
but someone might work it out
so now in the compose file i've actually
removed any port bindings
so this sql server is not port bound
but
it still is exposing a port it's still
listening for connections on that port
and it's listening for them inside of
the docker network
so this is why my demo application my
web application resides in its web
network publicly accessible and the db
network which is internally accessible
and only things that can access the
database are on that network
so we're going to launch this again
uh we'll wait for visual shooter to
crash then i'll just cry a little and
we'll clean up everything
but we'll give it a moment
there's still like a whole bunch of
steps in compose before it falls over
hey works first time
uh okay so so this will start up and i'm
not particularly interested in the web
but that'll open up again anyway
all right so everything's up and running
let's jump back to linkpad
if i was to refresh my sql server
connection
this will
ultimately time out because i didn't do
port binding as we saw in our node
examples earlier it won't connect
but i can still come here i'm going to
hit register
if we
set all the stuff in here appropriately
oops
it'll still talk to the sql server
i can still say apply migrations
so the website can still talk to the sql
server but you can't
it might be running on your machine but
you do not have access to it
that is unless you go say
docker
network ls so
just wanted to find out the names of the
networks okay so let's create an image
oh sorry let's create create a container
and we're going to join this network
that's in use so docker
run remove
dash
network
so i'm going to jump onto that network
and then just use the ubuntu
and we'll jump into bash
okay so if i was to go oh actually not
that one
sorry so the default ubuntu image
doesn't have ping installed
that can be a little bit of a nuisance
so i created one called ping
okay so if i was to go ping sql
can't do anything
if i was to
go docker network
work
sorry let's just grab that network again
so this time i want to jump onto the
database network
so docker run
rm network is going to be that aaron
ping
bin bash
okay so now if i go ping sql
there's our sql server
so network isolation basically means
that anything on that network can talk
to anything else that's on that network
but it can't talk to things that aren't
there so here because i'm on the seat on
the databases network i can talk to it
so i could if i had like this the
command line util to sql server i could
be using that to talk to sql server but
i don't have it
and whereas this one here it doesn't
know about the sql sql host it can't
access it so and that is how we can use
network isolation
from compose files to separate parts of
our architecture out
all right so i have one more demo that
i'm just going to let's close visual
studio because i don't need visual
studio open that
so i said that the uh the title of this
talk was docker from scratch
i just want to talk a bit about scratch
itself so scratch is kind of a special
concept with inside of docker
everything has to start from a base
image
but
the most basic base image that you start
from with docker is called scratch
so i can create a a container or sorry
create an image that then you turn into
a run into containers
from
scratch
the thing is that scratch is really bare
bones like it is
about running a single process it
doesn't give you anything it doesn't
have anything inside of it it doesn't
even have been sh the most primitive
shell in unix it doesn't have that
doesn't have bash nothing
but if you've got a process that you
want to execute you want to do it super
lightweight or you can do that with doc
with
with scratch
so
the only way that you can use scratch i
can't do docker run and specify scratch
as an image name because it's
technically not an image name but i can
create a docker file that says from
scratch
type back to the title
um
this case what i'm actually doing is i'm
using docker
to
run a go application i was trying to
think what was the most simple
application that i could run inside of
uh well compiled down to a native
process and that was go
i know nothing about writing go so i
copied the hello world demo uh so
i'm going to run
i have yeah i love a little go
application whoops
somewhere
i have app.go
it is really awesome anyone that knows
how to write go will know that that's
really awesome
i'm going to use docker run so i'm
actually going to run a container on
line 5
to run the go compiler because i don't
have go installed on my machine so i'm
going to run the go compiler out of a
container
it's going to generate me a binary
that's going to because it's volume
mounted right back to my windows machine
i'm then going to create an image using
my docker file it's going to copy that
binary into the root of the container
that's our root of the image
i'm then going to run that and then i'm
going to remove it all uh clean up after
myself
so this is how we get like the idea here
is we're starting to build out a like a
basic build process i'm using docker to
containerize
my ci cd process i'm building an
application uh there so
here is the
output from go and then we had a whole
bunch of stuff before that which was
compiling go
building image
running container cleaning up everything
after itself
and that is how you finally finish with
docker from scratch
so just some like closing on on kind of
what we've covered across in this talk
scratch is not particularly useful as an
image i just like just going to be
honest it's it's not a very useful one
unless you're basically creating your
own base images so you're creating
ubuntu or alpine or
any other kind of general purpose os
style
image with inside of docker
or you're trying to do something super
high performance
particularly if you're obviously you're
compiling something down to a native
process
then you can use scratch but it's not
going to be useful for a lot of things
asp.net applications you're not really
going to run them out of a scratch image
images are really great for
experimenting
uh
running a single use process is really
it's quite powerful i can i can stand up
something like unra because i have no
need to install winrar for the like one
time every three or four years that i
need to unriver and archive on my
machine or i can i want to just play
around with something in go because i
don't know i don't really know how to
programming go i don't know if i ever
want to become a go programmer but maybe
i want to just experiment see what it's
like basically try out the basic syntax
well rather than installing the go build
chain on my machine i can just run it
out of a container
compose is used and it's all about
representing environments that's what
we're doing with the docker compose file
we start building up services with
inside of that that represent the
applications we want to run and the
dependencies that those applications
have on each other so we can you know if
i have an application that needs sql
server and a redis case sure um it's
using rabbitmq and [ __ ] and a few
things like that i could i define those
all as services and how i can stand them
up um we used this at a client that i
was working with to basically represent
their dev environment because
they were using rabbit and redis and
[ __ ] and stuff like that and
you'd install redis on your first day
and like set all that stuff up on your
first day and then six months later your
implement your instance has been
configured completely differently to
prod because you've gone in there and
you tweaked some settings and stuff like
that well using the compose file we can
say this is what the standard
environment looks like and this is how
you stand that up and using all the same
configs that you'd be running in you
know
on a product environment or that i'm
running on my machine and that you're
running on your machine and you're
running on your machine we're running
the same thing it removes that well it
worked on my machine well how did you
configure your you know redis cache
everyone's running it exactly the same
i'm aaron pal that was docker from
scratch thank you very much
[Applause]